the success that you have found in
yourself you've duplicated that success
by aligning yourself uh with new Talent
with with being a part of the discovery
of some of the biggest names in the
business today more importantly the
biggest albums right when you go to
music well you can attach yourself to
the career of NW it's not about
attaching Kevin I don't like that word
give me a word it's about collaborating
okay okay you know better word I like it
yeah collaborating with some of the
smartest [__] and the most
talented [__] that ever stepped
in how do they how do they happen how
how are you Outsourcing said
opportunities at that time it's um the
only person that I ever heard on a demo
tape
that I really liked and [__] with in
the studio was Eminem
everything else is Word of Mouth uh it's
exactly what you said or you gotta hear
this guy hey
you got to hear Snoop you got to hear
this guy named Snoop okay
brought him in the studio
and he started rapping he didn't even
understand how to song structure or
anything like that I think doc taught
him how to do that [__] but
it just happened like that okay you know
um
has there was there ever a time with the
with the yard is that you were
collaborating with uh whether it was
Eminem Snoop 50 uh Kendrick right was
there ever a time where a conversation
had to be had even pot was there ever a
time where it was like hey man you know
either we're gonna do the work or we're
not did any of them ever present
themselves to be about anything but the
work no never it was always the work
always the work it was always the work
and it was always collaborating with the
creativity and seeing what we can do
next that could be amazing what the [__]
can we do next we're still having these
conversations I love long-term
relationships you know if I'm [__]
with you I'm hopefully I want to [__]
with you for life you know we're in
we're in a relationship where we're
making this music we're making money
we're getting creative it's not just a
one-off with me okay I love long-term
relationships so with it so so a work a
working environment with Dr Dre is what
like when when when I sign up to go into
studio with Dre am I signing up for
anywhere between 12 to 16 hours Studio
days yeah hopefully hopefully you're
signing up for a lifelong relationship
that's why I'm going into it okay we're
gonna make this music
and hopefully this is a stepping stone
to a [__] fantastic relationship
moving forward not just with the music
we can talk about life we can talk about
relationships we can talk about our kids
and whatever
that's what I look for we can grow and
this thing we should grow yeah right and
that's again it's a give and take
absolutely I'm giving you this and I
want something back absolutely you know
[Music]
thank you